[Music]
super bowl 56 is the first time that
cryptocurrency companies will be
advertising on the largest stage in the
world this moment with these companies
buying ads in the super bowl sort of
caps off what has been a long run up for
the cryptocurrency sector in terms of
its mainstream recognition and
acceptance and now what you are going to
see probably with these ads is that this
is a real sort of unveiling moment for
this entire sector i've missed out on a
lot but i am not going to miss out on
this so which companies are vying for
americans attention this football sunday
and what can we expect from the big
games new crypto advertisers ftx is
giving away the time their ad runs in
bitcoin today watching super bowl
commercials is arguably as much of an
american tradition as watching the game
itself so super bowl sunday is the most
expensive real estate on all of
television if you have a company that's
new and you want to cement its brand
name like become the next budweiser the
next coca-cola you need those eyeballs
in 2022 each 30-second ad slot went for
as much as 7 million dollars up from 5.6
million last year this year we are going
to be calling this the crypto ball
because there are
a slew of crypto companies that are
going to be advertising in the game and
around the game crypto bowl is a play on
the dot-com bowl of 2000 which saw ads
from a slew of internet related brands
many of which went on to fail
we know right now is that three
companies are going to be running ads in
the broadcast of the game itself
and they are
they're all exchanges they are coinbase
ftx and crypto.com
fortune favors the brave so far none of
those companies have shared much about
their upcoming commercials the crypto
companies have been particularly
secretive about what they're going to do
with their advertising this year they
definitely probably will rely on big
celebrities because that seems to be
what most
businesses that are new try to do
history is filled with almost last
october crypto.com released an ad
featuring matt damon you know what
a man in its past campaigns rival
exchange ftx featured tom brady
a fourth cryptocurrency exchange binance
is pursuing a more unconventional
strategy binance will run an ad campaign
around the game rather than buying ads
during the actual game on february 13th
you're gonna hear some of the biggest
names telling you to get into crypto but
they don't know you or your finances
only you do finances ads are interesting
in that they will be taking shots
basically taking shots at those others
saying don't rely on celebrities to make
your decision your investing decisions
for you go do your own research go
educate yourself first and then if you
decide you want to buy crypto well come
to us
and ironically they are going to be
using celebrities to deliver that
message finance and i are here to tell
you trust yourself and of course do your
own research
even companies that are not directly
related to cryptocurrencies are making a
point of exploring blockchain technology
budweiser said that during the game it
would run an online nft contest
for the past two decades the brewer has
outspent all other brands in advertising
at the super bowl budweiser is one of
the perennial advertisers always there
they have exclusive alcohol rights to
the game with the nfl and they're going
to return this year they're going to
bring their budweiser clydesdales back
um and again they're going to reflect
the pandemic in a little bit of a way
they're showing a clydesdale horse
that's been injured and then sort of
comes back to health and basically it's
to show
america and its fight against this virus
and how it's going to get up off the
dirt and it's going to keep going
last year some of the biggest spenders
like budweiser decided not to
participate in the super bowl because of
the pandemic everybody
last year had to be very careful because
you know not only were we in like still
in political turmoil as country and
divisiveness but the pandemic also was
sort of still around and really heavy
and people tried to play it safe they
definitely went more light-hearted
pretty sure with rocket mortgage you can
be certain not pretty sure i think it's
going to be a little bit more normal
than it was last year but i don't think
it's that easy to actually craft
something because we're still in this
really
you know hard place in this country